welcome back where he left off on
problem number 13 but let me start it
all over just so that we don't get
confused kind of doing the problem over
the course of two videos so number
thirteen it starts off with this pattern
three five minus five and what it says
in the problem is that each odd-numbered
term or each even number term is two
more than the previous term and then
each odd number term is negative one
times the previous term right so you
know to go what we started with three so
let me stay let me say term I'll be
right here term term and then value and
then what we did maybe we could call
that f of X right or the function how
did we how did we go from one value to
the next so if we make a table C term
one is values three and that's just the
starting one term two is five that's
because we added two right we added two
to three and we could write three plus
two is equal to five three plus two is
equal to five term three is minus five
and that's because minus one times this
five times this five are these arrows is
equal to minus five and then we add
again I'm gonna switch colors just to
keep it interesting
oh whoops so term for we're gonna add
it's gonna be minus five
it's gonna be minus five plus two which
equals minus three minus 3 then term
five is going to be minus three minus 3
times minus one which equals three again
right and I think you can see how we're
getting these patterns we just keep
switching between adding two and
multiplying by negative one and then so
term six is going to be what it's going
to be this
plus two which is five and I think
you're seeing the pattern again let me
do a bunch more and I'll do it outside
of the scope of this chart but term
seven let me term term value term seven
it's gonna be what its gonna be minus
one times that so minus five and you see
the pattern now term eight is gonna be
minus three term nine is going to be
term nine is going to be what - three -
three
so from here here we added two so we
multiply it by negative one so it's
gonna be three again right and you could
just experiment with yourself once you
understand how this pattern works just
keep multiple once you understand how
the sequence works do a bunch of terms
you know until you see a cycle and
that's that's the key thing in any SAT
problem when they ask you like what is
the hundredths term it's gonna have a
cycle because they don't expect you to
sit and write out a hundred terms
because you would run out of time so
they ask you the hundred term there's
probably gonna you know the pattern
probably repeats every three or four or
five or at most six terms and then you
can use that to figure out what the
hundredth term is so here we see that
the pattern repeats to see 3 5 negative
5 negative 3 3 5 negative 5 negative 3 3
so here you see it repeats every fourth
term right this is kind of one cycle
then 3 5 negative 3 and this is another
circle right cycle so it has this 4
pattern so can we can we come up with
any any any term that is a multiple 4
what is our value well at for our values
minus 3 what's the next month four of
eight at eight our values minus three so
in general and if we did 12 we'd also
get minus three right if you wanted if
you don't believe me should try it out
so any multiple of four
we know our value is minus three so what
I do is they want to know the 55th term
they want to know the 55th term 55th
term
so what is the value what is what term
is a multiple of four that is closest to
55 let's see it's 56 a multiple of four
we have 56
56 let's see that's 1014 times four is
56 right so the 56th term we know the
56th term because this is because 56 is
a multiple of four just like four and
eight and twelve so the 56 therm is
going to 56 I have trouble saying that
maybe you have a little Lisp 56th term
is negative three right because it's a
multiple of four if the 56th term is
negative three what is the 55th term
well the term before the negative three
term is always the negative five term
right up here negative three it's always
negative five so the answer is negative
five is the 55th term and that is choice
a very good all right let's move on to
the next question age inverted cars I
know that one's a little hard and those
you always just have to experiment a
little bit try to see the cycle and then
make sure you have your terms right you
know that you're starting on the first
term as opposed to the zero term and
then figure out what the easiest value
is as close to what they're asking as
possible and then you can kind of move
backwards or forwards that's how I do it
that's so you don't get too confused
with the shifts on the terms all right
number 14 in the XY plane the equation
of line L is I can let me write that
down number 14 the equation of line L is
y is equal to 2x plus 5 if the line M is
the reflection of L in the x-axis what
is the equation of line M so I'm gonna
draw a graph for you just so you
understand what I'm doing but if I'm the
real ICT you really don't have to do
this cuz you would once again run out of
time but let me oh man I'm gonna run out
of time if I can't draw a straight line
I'm being a stickler for this oh I still
couldn't do it I'll move forward so
that's that was the y-axis that's the
x-axis better okay so this line so y
equals 2x plus 5 so if you remember from
our our kind of our
you know slope and y-intercept modules
the y-intercepts gonna be five right
here and then the lines gonna have a
slope of two right so the lines gonna
look something like this you know it's
gonna look something like this
that's line L lied L line L something
this is line L and then we want to know
we they say line M is the reflection of
L and the x-axis or reflection it kind
of view the x axis is the x axis so it's
like if we were looking this enough in a
pool of water the reflection would look
would would be like if you took this and
flipped it over the x axis so the line m
is gonna look something like this it's
gonna look something like this line m is
gonna look like this so a couple of
things it's gonna it's like the mirror
image if we flipped it right it's like
we flipped it over the axis so if the
y-intercept here is 5 the y-intercept
here is gonna be minus 5 right because
we just flipped it and similarly if this
if every you know if everyone this moves
up to right because that's its slope
rise over run is to for every one we
move here to the right we're gonna go
down to so the slope is going to be the
negative of this or negative two so line
m so this is line m the equation of line
m is going to be y is equal to it's
gonna have the negative slope right the
same slope that just moves in the
downward direction so it's gonna be
minus 2x and then its y-intercept is
instead of plus five is gonna be minus
five minus 2x minus 5 and that is choice
a it looks like the next problem
involves a lot of drawing and i only
have a minute and a half left in this
video so i will do the next problem in
the next video i will see you soon